[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le chantier durera un an du gros œuvre
et des artisans qui se succèdent
l'isolation la charpente la couverture
et puis une quarantaine de fenêtres
réparties sur 3 niveaux c'est le savoir
faire du métal
de prendre les mesures pour pouvoir
réaliser les fenêtres que je vais devoir
poser dans un mois à peu près du travail
jusqu'à fin novembre 3 ouvriers ils
seront dédiés un chantier à 200.000
euros un tiers du chiffre annuel de
l'entreprise
maintenant on est obligé de sélectionner
et forcément on va sur les chantiers ou
qui c'est un peu plus volumineux et non
plus le chantier le chantier à 1000
euros
trier refuser parce que Franck ne peut
pas suivre la cadence trop de demandes
et trop peu de salariés pour l'absorber
son père a créé la société il y a 45 ans
un héritage une affaire de famille
aujourd'hui le fils emploie 5 artisans
il en recherche deux de plus en vain
le serrurier métallier est rare sur le
marché du travail on a plus privilégié
d'autres métiers émergents comme
l'informatique etc qui nous a coupé un
peu l'herbe sous le pied et on a poussé
un peu le 80% de bacheliers a fait qu'on
a un peu délaissé nos métiers artisanaux
alors le trentenaire avec une dizaine
d'années d'expérience polyvalent et
capable de gérer tout type de chantier
serait évidemment le candidat rêver
mais cette ouvrier est quasi introuvable
il y en a très peu sur le marché de
l'emploi ils sont déjà en emploi donc il
y en a qui veulent pas bouger c'est très
très difficile à convaincre c'est ces
gens là quoi moi je n'ai pas les mêmes
avantages qu'une grosse entreprise j'ai
pas de treizième mois j'ai pas de
véhicule de société à lui fournir
j'ai une mutuelle mais vraiment de base
et j'ai pas une mutuelle complète comme
peut le
prétend d'une grosse entreprise
en attendant à défaut les intérimaires
défilent des contrats de quelques jours
ou plusieurs semaines mais le
recrutement en CDI reste une priorité là
fabrication de pièces métalliques dans
garde-corps portail etc brise-soleil etc
sous la grande mode en ce moment
désormais Franck multiplie ses chances
et poste lui-même régulièrement des
annonces sur les réseaux sociaux
on n'allait pas chercher du travail sur
sur Linkedin un jeune maintenant va pas
aller pousser la porte forcément Pôle
Emploi systématiquement il est sur son
portable et puis il va se jeter la le
LinkedIn
enfin tout ce qui peut y avoir comme et
puis entre copains et là il y a le
bouche à oreille il y a du boulot là
j'ai vu ça là et en fait il se
communique que par ça quoi donc en fait
faut être présent maintenant
pratiquement plus là-dessus que ailleurs
quoi faute de recrutement Franck sera
contraint de former un apprenti à partir
de septembre
à Bourges Pascal et Christophe sont deux
associés bien connus
bah je trouve que pas beaucoup changé
l'adresse emporte encore les stigmates
leur restaurant Le Cercle seul étoilé de
la ville a fermé ses portes en novembre
la vie continue il y aura certainement
d'autres réussites d'autres
moments sympas et bon c'est mais la
maison est belle en plus c'est ça qui
est frustrant et voilà on aurait pu
elle aurait pu être la nôtre aussi et
bon voilà il y a quand même un coup de
cœur à l'époque cette maison
les deux chefs ont passé neuf ans à la
tête du cercle avec dans les derniers
mois des difficultés inédites et en
fonctionnement au ralenti à l'époque
quatre postes de serveur étaient à
pourvoir depuis plusieurs semaines
on n'avait pas de candidature quoi on
avait pas de CV effectivement qui est
arrivé donc on s'est retrouvé dans une
situation moi j'avais plus qu'une
personne pour m'épauler
en salle moi à la base je suis cuisinier
même je me souviens aussi la dernière
année d'ouverture d'avoir remplacé
notre pâtissier la moitié de l'année la
moitié du temps quoi donc en plus de
tout le travail qui avait à effectué
c'était aussi une situation compliquée
et encore plus pour un restaurant étoilé
la restauration est un secteur en mal de
main d'oeuvre mais il n'est pas le seul
au total
55000 offres d'emploi ont été publiées
en 2022 dans la région
41% de plus que l'année précédente
ce jour-là une vingtaine de candidats
participent à une session collective de
recrutement ils sont sans emploi et
recherche une activité en intérim
bien évidemment si vous engagez sur ces
missions là avec nous vous engagez sur
les horaires vous êtes dispo sur les
lieux et sur les tâches que vous allez
faire
le recrutement est aujourd'hui très
dynamique sur le marché du travail
l'offre de poste est plus importante que
la demande c'est une période de pleine
emploi aujourd'hui le plein emploi ce
que ça veut dire c'est que beaucoup
d'entreprises ont besoin et en demande
donc il y a une activité économique et
que le marché de candidat se restreint
et donc de moins en moins de choix pour
les entreprises
désormais les candidats dominent donc le
marché résultat des demandeurs d'emploi
plus attentifs à la pénibilité à
l'équilibre entre vie professionnelle et
vie personnelle plus soucieux du salaire
et de l'image de la société la marque
employeur peut tomber dans des
entreprises ou avec une bonne renommée
mais l'ambiance qui est pas terrible et
vice versa et des fois le salaire ça
fait pas tout il y a aussi l'ambiance
les conditions de travail j'ai une
petite fille qui habitait avec moi du
coup je peux pas travailler en de 8
comment ça à 5 heures ou finir à 21h je
peux pas c'est qui qui va la récupérer
chez la nourrice
au patron de se vendre d'être attirant
et convaincant
une leçon appliquée par Christophe et
Pascal
après l'échec du cercle à Bourges
les deux chefs sont parvenus à maintenir
l'activité de leur haute établissement
les petits plats du bourbon 16 salariés
en salle et en cuisine
et ici pas d'embauche prévu l'équipe est
au complet
aujourd'hui il y a un socle solide qui
nous permet de
continuer à travailler avec un peu plus
de sérénité le fruit d'un recrutement
différent pour constituer la brigade les
deux patrons ont adapté leur méthode
avant on regardait beaucoup les CV on
voilà on s'intéressait beaucoup au
parcours de professionnels de de du
candidat mais effectivement encore une
fois aujourd'hui nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est vraiment c'est une
mentalité c'est et on se rend compte
d'ailleurs qui a beaucoup de jeunes
malgré ce qu'on peut entendre un petit
peu partout il y a encore beaucoup de
jeunes qui qui croient en ce métier
après à nous aussi de leur amener des
choses c'est normal ça c'est un échange
ça donnant-donnant les horaires et jours
de travail sont aménagés le restaurant
ferme à Noël le service prend fin à
13h30 et 21h15 et pas d'ouverture 7
jours sur 7
on sait qu'on travaille du lundi soir au
samedi et dimanche c'est vrai que c'est
bien de pas travailler comme ça on peut
rester avec sa famille
voir des amis faire des choses et même
avoir le lundi aussi le lundi matin
c'est bien aussi comme ça on peut
s'occuper de certaines choses ça c'est
un argument oui de quoi séduire la
nouvelle génération de cuisine pour
étoffer l'équipe les chefs ont misé sur
la jeunesse
bonjour ça me plaît bien ici donc
pourquoi pas rester quoi
pardon
des apprentis cet au total les
professionnels de demain à la fois un
pari sur l'avenir et une solution
durable pour pallier les difficultés de
recrutement là pour le coup eux ils ont
déjà un pied dans le monde de
l'entreprise et vraiment et si s'ils
arrivent à honorer leur contrat bah je
pense qu'on les on les reverra plus tard
chez nous ça c'est important
comment garder son personnel quels
arguments pour fidéliser le salarié déjà
présent comment hacer le gâté pour le
retenir
dans l'Indre à leverou il est 10h un
vendredi comme un autre et petite
cagettes les lustres
Manu est passionné de décoration faite
maison un loisir son passe-temps
lorsqu'elle ne travaille pas elle colle
plie et façonne de petits objets j'aime
ça je trouve ça
on pense à rien d'autre on gère on
innove Angelina dans la tête faut que je
le fasse tout de suite
depuis un an et demi elle ne travaille
que quatre jours une semaine sur deux
son vendredi est libre
ça nous permet de faire beaucoup de
choses et puis déjà du repos et c'est un
weekend de trois jours ou 4 de 3 jours
tout le monde n'a pas vocale de trois
jours et
ça nous permet voilà de prendre des
rendez-vous de bricoler à la maison de
faire pas mal de petites choses quoi
qu'on peut pas faire la semaine
un nouveau rythme mais pas moins de
temps de travail 35 heures les semaines
de 4 jours
39 heures les semaines de 5 jours
Manu est employé à quelques kilomètres
de là à Écueillé chez CBN
1000 mètres carrés une cinquantaine de
salariés qui confectionne chaque année
45 000 chemises et pantalons pour des
grandes marques de luxe
alors au début ils sont montés tout
simplement et puis bah je les rabâche
surplis tout autour
le secteur de l'habillement haut de
gamme est porteur la demande en hausse
le made in France a besoin de petites
mains alors quatre jours de travail et
trois de repos au moment de postuler
forcément l'argument fait mouche
j'espère trouver un truc comme ça et en
fait
c'est arrivé donc du coup bah j'ai dit
pourquoi pas essayer
vous êtes contente
qui est pas très très grand donc c'est
l'opportunité aussi de passer du temps
avec lui plus que quelqu'un qui
bosserait le vendredi en plus
Séverine et Laetitia ont récemment
rejoint l'équipe je lève mon pied je
bascule après trois mois de formation
sur site au cœur de l'atelier là on va
déjà démarrer par la première opération
c'est-à-dire qu'on va piquer on va faire
une surpiqûre de 1 cm Sandra vous restez
là et puis les autres vont commencer à
prendre des petits poignets puis on va
commencer à s'exercer des sessions de
formation de 10 semaines qui se
poursuivent avec de nouveaux candidats
et toujours un CDI à la clé
5 embauche il y a trois semaines
cinq
j'espère six sept huit de cette
formation là et encore derrière
effectivement l'envie de positionner une
nouvelle étape de formation
voilà des perspectives un futur qui se
dessine ces BN se développe la
productivité est au rendez-vous et les
salaires augmentent plus 8% en un an si
demain vous enlevez le 30 du mois et le
papier il y a plus personne qui vient
travailler moi le premier soyons honnête
donc après c'est de dire soit on se dit
le matin je vais passer ce qu'on se dit
ouais je vais travailler OK dans une
entreprise où je me sens bien et ça
c'est important
plaire pour recruter
faire le pari du bien-être au travail et
de la rémunération juste le pari du
temps consacré à la formation à
l'apprentissage
sur un marché de l'emploi où l'offre et
la demande s'inverse les candidats
devenus rares et indispensables sont de
plus en plus courtisés flatté eux qui
désormais on le pouvoir de choisir